hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round 10 of the
2022 tata still chess masters uh today
is a rest day so we have some time to
check out uh a couple of games that we
haven't uh and the game that we're
starting is fabiana caruana versus
rihard rapport really an exciting one
especially since rapport has um the
black pieces against fabi which is not
easy for anyone and yesterday we had a
well we had that uh unfortunate event
with uh magnus and karjakin at that end
in the the very uh a quick draw but then
we had a brilliant brilliant game that
lasted seven hours between prague and
vidit and that uh well really improved
my day
but uh okay let's get let's get to this
one and then we're gonna discuss the
standings a little bit more uh for those
of you who might have missed yesterday's
uh uh coverage so here fabi with the
white pieces opens with c4 he goes for
the english opening we have e6 knight to
c3 so the argent core defense and now
knight to f6 with e4 uh this is the most
popular line nowadays and now we have c5
uh so very very interesting um uh we
have e5 challenging the knight and not
knight back to g8 so it looks a little
bit weird you know that you really
shouldn't bring your pieces back to
starting squares but this is a variation
and of course the both of them know this
so d4 uh we see capture sunday for queen
captures on d4 and now knight to c6
gaining a tempo on the queen so queen to
f4 and now d6 challenging this e5 pawn
so knight to f3 adding a defender to the
e5 pawn and the the position has been
reached before and interestingly daniel
dubo had this position with white twice
and he both won uh won both of his games
uh one against uh pisho one against uh
kovalev uh and um uh in one game knight
h6 was played in the other game knights
the e7 was played here rapper continues
with knight to h6 and now
in both of those games that
we've mentioned bishop to d2 was played
but here we have e captures on the e6 by
fabi and it is now as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game and the e
captures on d6 is incredibly interesting
uh because it's not uh
in the engine's top choice not even in
the top three bishop to d2 the move that
the dubai played is so very interesting
if this is something that fabi cooked up
himself or maybe he
isn't familiar with this at all and not
he's just finding moves over the board
you know it is just very interesting so
here we have bishop captures on d6 uh of
course as of move nine we have a
completely new game i know some of you
really enjoy knowing this fact so bishop
captures on d6 we win the pawn back and
now queen g5 here fabio offers a queen
trade uh rapper to greece uh you could
just castle and then maybe white
captures and we capture back with the
rook but here we have queen captures
knight captures sorry bishop captures uh
in the now f5 by rapport a very
interesting move
uh for one taking away the e4 square
from the white knight other than this
you are preparing uh some very nice
king-sized expansion if white doesn't
capture this we're going to play knight
f7 h6 g5 and we're already pushing and
it's a it's kind of a there to fabi if
he wants to capture the the knight on h6
for example captures capture so you ruin
black spawn structure here but it's not
all that easy black still has the bishop
pair and let's say something like g3
bishop d7 both players have to finish
development castles castles uh white
will also probably castle queenside
attack the bishop bishop somewhere now
let's say c5 and it's not uh it's not
clear uh i'm pretty sure everyone in the
in the top 20 in the world would pick
the side with the bishop pair here as is
just that there's a lot of play on both
sides of the board so instead of fabi
castle's queen side uh and now bishop to
c5 our bishop is attacked here we have
knight the e5 now with a nice little
trick uh yes the f2 pawn is hanging but
uh so is uh
so are a lot of other things for example
if you capture the knight and no it's
not a free knight there's rook d8
checking if seven and upward loses the
rook so rapper plays knight to f7 this
is what we were planning to play uh we
want to start our expansion here and our
knight captures on c6 so fab used this
little trick to mess up rapport's pawn
structure here so b captures on um on c6
now black has three pawn islands uh and
now bishop back to e3 the bishop here is
hanging so we have to move it bishop to
e3 and rapper also captures uh messing
up fabi's pawn structure so now fabi
also with the
uh three pawn islands and now uh black
of course has a light square bishop you
want to play e5 you want to free up that
light square bishop but uh
there's no rush it's not like white can
stop e5 so here king to e7 first we want
to get the rook into the game but um
either king the a7 and then e5 or e5
king e7 both is fine bishop e2 fabi
continues development and now g5 so
there's nothing fab you can really do
about this king side expansion knight to
a4 uh there's no b pawn or d pawn so the
c5 square will be a great for for the
white knight uh h5 rapper continues
advancing those pawns knight to c5 and
now even h4 and here uh favi wants to do
something about this uh uh expansion so
he starts with the g4 he wants to um
well he would have very much enjoyed
black captured here but of course the
rapper will not do this he plays knight
to e5 now he's uh just threatening to
win a pawn here and fabi has to decide
how to react if you capture then this is
perfectly fine for black those pawns are
just monsters uh what fabi should do is
rook h to g1 and defend the pawn like
this but
if you don't see whether opera will play
then you play rook to d4 as it's a much
more active move uh but there's a
problem with this move uh so feel free
to pause the video here and try to
figure out what fobby missed while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this well
seemingly hidden idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is knight captures on g4
that's the good stuff yes so
congratulations to everyone who found
this the point is the rook on d4 is very
vulnerable and the move e5 will chase
away
the rook completely from the fourth rank
so the rook isn't really guarding the g4
square and now there isn't um a better
move than bishop captures on g4 here the
fobby plays this now just e5 and now the
rook has to move and we're gonna pick up
the bishop here so rook to d2 and now we
captured the bishop and now okay we are
up upon it's a double g pawn but still
you will be able to to create a very
nice pass pawn here so knight the d3
going after the e5 pawn and the the the
problem with this is that for example if
king e6 which seems like a move you want
to play then e4 uh and uh how are you
getting your uh king into the game uh
all the squares are taken what's the
light square bishop gonna do now there's
there are no squares that you can use to
make the bishop useful so this would be
this would actually be okay for fabi so
instead we have rook to h6 now offering
not just the e51 but also maybe e5 g for
c6 all depending on what fob you place
so knight captures on e5 and rook to e6
now attacking the knight and going after
the the pawn here which seems like uh
a bit of a counter-intuitive move
because the rook on e6 prevents your
bishop from
guarding the g4 square and now fabi
grabs another pawn with knight captures
on g4 and the guards the e3 pawn so here
rapport plays rook to e4 attacks the
knight knight to f2 attacks the rook and
now not rook captures an e3 that's an
isolated pawn so we will probably be
able to win it later on but also maybe
it's not even important for this game
our plan is to play g4 g3 create a pass
pawn and win this way and this is maybe
a second weakness that we can use
to sort of augment our first
advantage so here rook captures on c for
check this is much better rook the c2
and here are upper trades we have
captures captures and bishop to e6 now
and we have this end game now with
completely equal material but
uh the two against one on the king's
side uh is definitely an advantage for
rapport also he has a bishop against
tonight with play on both sides of the
board that eight you pawn is already
hanging so black is definitely better
here how much well that's on fabi2
try and uh
uh prevent and and for rapper to try and
prove so here rook the g1 trying to give
up the a2 pawn for the uh g5 pawn but
just rook to f8 we had challenged the
knight here so knight to d3 and now g4
we are starting um at the advancement of
our or pawn majority on the kings side
knight to f for now challenging the
bishop and also hoping that rapper
blunders if bishop captures an a29 g6
check picks up the rook and now white is
winning so after knight f4 bishop to f5
with check and now king to d2
we have rook to d8 with check now comes
king to e2 and now king to f6 and now
the problem is
yes the material is equal that of course
everyone can see but there isn't a
useful move for white here so it's very
hard to figure it out if you could play
something like rook to d1 challenge
black's rook on the d file then i guess
it would be perfectly fine but it's it's
losing by four so rook captures king
captures and now king e5 your king is
just much more active let's say b4 you
really don't have any useful moves here
king e4 we're gonna defend our e3 pawn
and not just g3 we create a pass pawn
captures captures uh white without
really
a useful move you are controlling all of
the squares here if white moves back
then we pick up the e3 pawn there's just
not
nothing you can do here you can play a4
we're gonna play bishop g for check king
to d2 or you move uh at the f1 and then
give up the e3 pawn so let's say you
want to keep the pawn but then you give
up the f3 square king f3 and that's it
knight to d3 hoping for maybe something
like this and then we deliver check and
give up the knight for a pawn uh but
even this you don't have to allow you
can just force white to run out of moves
it's it's a really fun position for
example a5 bishop to f5 uh take away all
the squares from the from the white king
so you're not allowing this you're not
allowing this uh for let's say knight
back to f4 we're gonna play a6 and white
is out of moves uh whatever you're
playing i remove the knight and then
this is winning or you move the king
then we pick up the e3 pawn and okay
maybe knight g2 check we play king d3 we
pick up all of the pawns here and now
it's easily winning so uh rook to d1
would be nice but it's losing by force
so b3 was played by fabi uh b3 or b4a
for everything is possible uh it's just
not very useful so here we have a five
bar upward king the e1 and now king e5
black has a very clear way of uh
increasing the activity and pushing for
more advantage knight the g2 now going
after the pawn here and just a rook h8
defending the pawn and now uh knight the
uh knights to f4 uh
here king to f2 would have been a bit
more resilient but still it would be
incredibly difficult to hold
after knight to f4 it's just uh much
much better for black because here it
upper pushes g3 it seems like you've
given up a pawn but not really if h
captures on g3 we don't capture we
advance our past pawn and that's it if
king f2 we just play h2 rook to h1 and
bishop e4 uh it's a game over knight g2
okay you've blocked this but now rook f8
check the king has to move and you win
the knight so there's that so here king
g2 by fabi and now bishop to e4
attacking the rook here rook to d2 and
now h3 even
so
those pawns are just impossible to stop
if h captures h2 is winning there's no
stopping h1 so here fabi plays a3 he
plays something just to see what rapport
will play and now g2 uh
will have to wait a little bit first
rook to d8 rapport finishes the game in
style uh because the rook cannot be
captured if you capture the rook then g
captures on h2 and you cannot prevent
promotion so here rook to b2 by fabi but
now just bishop to f3 and after this uh
beautiful move it was in this position
on move 42 that fabiano corona resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done as you can see black controls all
of these squares so whatever white does
rook to d1 will be checkmate or right or
not whatever y does white could stop the
checkmate but then however you stop the
checkmate if you move the rook from the
second rank then this is just winning
and if you play rook d2 then black very
happily trades captures captures g
captures on h2 and now the h1 move will
win the game
so really a a very nice game by by
rapport fabi made that one little
mistake and it's okay it's you might say
it's a very unlike uh fabi to make such
a mistake as he is a
former member of the 2800 club not only
that he's the former wheelchair
championship challenger uh but uh this
is chess and in chess no one is safe so
here just to rook d4 and that's it now
it's all rappered from here uh he played
incredibly well he never gave fabio a
chance to to reorganize himself and that
was uh as you see more than enough to to
win the game uh with black pieces
nonetheless against uh uh fabiano corona
so for those of you who maybe missed it
yesterday these are the standings so
magnus still leading the tournament with
seven out of ten and with seven out of
ten magnus actually is winning one
rating point so far so we'll see if he
finishes the tournament on a positive
note he's facing vidit next we also
mentioned that it would be great for
vedic if he actually defeated
pragernanda uh because then he would
have a clear shot if he takes down
magnus he takes the lead in the
tournament now it's not going to be as
pleasant but still of course you're
playing magnus he will do his best uh
then anish uh
install second with six and a half then
rapport climbs all the way to third
tying with mamadara with six five and a
half points uh by yeshipenko karyakin
and vidit with five we have fabiana
karwana uh young she's
forest with four and a half sam shanklin
with four daniel lubo and pragananda
with three and a half and niels
grandelius in last place with three out
of ten
so really really exciting stuff um very
much enjoying the tournament we'll see
what happens will magnus be able to
win the tournament and if he does
will he uh also win some raiding points
by by winning the tournament because
that's a a
bit of a problem for him since he he is
so much higher rated than everyone else
even if he wins first place in a
tournament he can still lose the rating
point so he has to not just win the
tournament he has to crush it in order
to win rating points uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank thomas earle trevor
for tado souza going goku khan william
rose and benjamin davidson for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event
until it finishes uh thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day